people should not panic calm down help
one another and not become selfish in
the in the face of crisis my name is
Connor aid I'm in Wuhan China and I'm
one of the first Brits to contract
karela virus so the end of November that
I first became sick and during this
stage the first symptoms were just a
common cold and the problem with the
common cold is you don't think it's
serious
[Music]
[Music]
during that time cough sniffles this
sort of pain behind the eyes sinuses and
that's a stage where it's most risky
because you can inadvertently spread it
to other people it was at that stage I
really didn't know what it was and
nobody else knew what it was it was
something that really wasn't heard of at
that time the first symptoms are
definitely mild you definitely not going
to be going to work during that stage
but you're not going to die it's the
second of third stages that are that are
more serious if the problem with the
coronaviruses you get better before we
get worse so I got better from the cold
thinking I was getting better and that's
when it hit me and got worse so from the
common cold I got hit with the flu now
people say off just the flu this was bad
flu obviously man flu and you think but
it was bad it was timed well and I
really wasn't feeling good so the flu
stage I was in bed I was watching movies
just just feeling bad about myself from
the flu I had I had massive ear problems
and also throw problems I was coughing
so much my voice died them I sounded
like a frog now this this stage where I
had the flu it really felt like I'm in
here with a truck it was difficult to
move difficult to do anything not only
physical symptoms but mental symptoms it
was a case I just didn't want to do
anything new it was it was debilitating
the virus comes it gets better before it
gets worse you have the cold it gets
better you get the flu it gets better
then it progresses to the pneumonia and
this is where it was the most scariest
this is because I'd never experienced
this before it felt like you were
breathing through one lung through a
paper bag you get up to go into the
bathroom and you have the breath and you
just can't get that full breath I didn't
feel like I was going to die but really
was not well at all now the problem I
had was that there was no testing kids
available and it did take a while for
anybody to develop a testing kit and so
I wasn't tested for a long time my
samples were not tested until later on
when those tests leakiest
did comic field
[Music]
this is the last bit of coke I have I'm
not sure when I can get more things like
that IRA luxury it certainly makes you
take for granted what you have access to
everyday businesses that will want busy
and now I've been shut for more than 40
days each one of them all locked up and
the people that own them are probably
stuck in their apartments like everybody
else
no private individual is allowed to go
shopping everything's done on a
community scale specific items like coke
shaving cream and razors it's impossible
to get I can't get anything like that I
can't get delivered the shops are closed
things I can get is like vegetables
carrots potatoes onions meat wise it's
done in bulk so I've been getting big
pieces of pork belly bags of dumplings
can't buy chicken legs can't buy chicken
breasts it's the whole thing and that
will get delivered to our gate now we're
not allowed to actually leave the gate
from there they'll call out to a number
you go up and they'll pass you the food
on a stick and a long stick so they
don't have to you have to go close to
you so you get your food and then you
you go back back to isolation this is
how the shops work now the shop owners
individually bagged your items and then
they pack it up for you to deliver if
you do have to actually leave the
community you have to have your ID card
have to be scammed out and then scammed
back in when you get scammed in again
they take your temperature
they'll disinfect your hands and that
sort of thing and depending obviously
they don't want to disinfect your
clothes but it really really isn't
enough resources to do that here so in
regards to exactly the lockdown
procedures we got told almost 3:00 a.m.
that there was going to be a lockdown
I got the message on my phone within
half an hour I left the house and went
to the 24-hour supermarket that's just
below our apartment block and I bought
supplies from there and luckily I did
because the next day it was packed of
pandemonium there was people everywhere
trying to buy things and that's probably
one of the problems as people panic
people should not panic people in the UK
need to not panic they need to calm down
help one another and not become selfish
in the in the face of crisis